all right oh yeah you mentioned mariota
earlier i did one of us did we both did
i think mariota now on the raiders
depth chart but not in the building yet
because it was rookie manny camp
for las vegas uh i i still can't get a
feel for where the raiders are right now
you look at the deconstruction of the
offensive line and then the partial
reconstruction of the offensive line by
bringing back guys like richie incognito
then the first round decision to take
alex leatherwood when christian darasaw
was available and a lot of criticism of
the raiders for that
uh one of the only teams that got
criticized for its first round pick
because the whole
etiquette at this point is praise and
hype praise and hype
everyone hope hope hope glass half full
except for alex leatherwood going to the
raiders
he's kind of a weird vibe right now with
that team and there was no real news
that came out
of their rookie mini camp this weekend
which i guess is good news
but uh you know that's that's uh that's
kind of where we are
yeah they got they they gotta like the
las vegas raiders is like you're right
there's no
theme or anything to hit on it's like
las vegas raiders 2021
prove it that's what it should say next
to their like
their logo prove it like yeah young guys
that you've been drafted
prove that you're worthy of the job john
gruden
you know big year going to the year four
four prove it
that you're worthy of it derek carr yeah
you showed us last year
i mean to me it's just about now they
got to start grooming some of these
young guys that they've drafted
and they got it's like time to put up or
shut up there with the raiders to a
degree
not that they got to go to the playoffs
and make a big play off run
but they are at the point where yeah
they're a team that we saw
improvement from last year you know to a
degree but maybe not quite the way we
were expecting at the end of the year
i think we thought maybe they'd be in
the mix a little bit more than where
they were
that kind of like made things a little
disappointing when you talk about the
raiders overall
so that that's where it is a big year
because there's just so many unproven
commodities
whether it be draft picks free agent
signings
the coaches whatever it just hasn't all
come together there quite yet to be
anything special and that's where it's
like you just don't know
which way this team is teetering right
now
especially with this off season like you
said the reconstruction of the offensive
line
and an interesting dynamic that we're
keeping an eye on as it relates to
raiders coach john gruden the only time
we have heard from him the entire
year since the regular season ended in
the raiders for the third straight
season under
gruden did not make it to the playoffs
he did that chris collinsworth podcast
with richard sherman
openly tampered with sherman during the
podcast there has been nothing else from
gruden nothing pre-free agency post-free
agency
pre-draft during draft post draft
this past weekend there was no media
access or
zoom availability for anyone
no rookies no coaches no one and my
understanding is that there's
some pressure being put on some of these
teams via the pro football
writers association to make guys
available
the reporters can't be there because of
the pandemic teams are choosing to make
guys available
some teams aren't and what the raiders
are doing is making no one other than
mike mayok yeah available right
mayok is available and available and
available gruden's nowhere to be seen
the players are nowhere to be seen it's
just kind of a strange thing right now
and
i i don't know if they're just trying to
set up an us against the world vibe or
what
gruden's upset he got called out for
tampering with richard sherman well you
know what one way to avoid that don't
tamper with richard sherman
either way gruden's nowhere to be seen
and it is kind of strange
and it gets more conspicuous as it goes
on it does well i know that like i
texted you
during around i think round one like i
did i thought it was even weird
and again i didn't rewind and go back
and look
but maybe i need to i don't think gruden
was
in the room during round one with alex
leatherwood in the pick you know when
they showed the raiders war room
and people congratulating each other and
doing all that
there was no gruden to be found i
thought that was odd let alone all the
other things that you've just talked
about
so i don't know it is a big year for
that that football team and that
organization
you know it like i said it's just a lot
of hey
you know we heard it from mayok a little
bit you know guys who
they've committed to whether it's money
draft picks or whatever
like it's got to be better it's just got
to be better
whether it's jonathan abrams at safety
got to be better
damon arnett keeping his cool and you
know playing the right way
got to be better there you heard all of
those type of things so
you know that that's where it's going to
be interesting henry ruggs top 15 pick
of receiver
yeah it was good last year but it's got
to be better to be a top 15 pick
i feel like the whole team is like
that's the theme you could just
continually say like yeah
okay but it's gotta be better like
that's what it's gotta be there's no
marquee unit or anything to look at on
the team right now to just go
wow they got that and if they can build
around that then they're gonna be okay
everything's like you said it's kind of
like uh i'm not sure
yeah it's okay uh okay yeah but
and that's not a great way to feel about
your football team
well especially not with the kansas city
chiefs in the division that's yes
the chargers ready to improve
dramatically in justin herbert's second
year with brandon staley as the head
coach
the broncos getting mentioned repeatedly
and it took us 26 minutes to mention
aaron rodgers but they're tied to aaron
rodgers and
the raiders rogers wish list the raiders
are on the
the rogers whistle list and there's been
no sign
no indication no sense the raiders are
even remotely interested in making a run
at aaron rodgers which
which seems bizarre if he wants you
don't you at least explore isn't there
something and and i know that they you
know they they're all in with derek carr
and
yeah i don't know you well still if you
could take derek carr aaron rodgers
chris you're taking aaron rodgers
definitely i mean yes no doubt about it
no doubt but i guess
here's the things that that come to my
mind when
when you hear that one yeah derek carr
they program the robot like you've
talked to me like we've talked about but
that's not going to be like make it or
break it the other thing is is like yeah
aaron rodgers is great but we just
talked about their damn team and they're
like yeah
and it's like first off you know okay
you're gonna trade that and what are you
gonna have as a team what you're gonna
trade away more future assets
and things like that to where you just
go what what the hell can we possibly
build here
we don't have a great foundation and now
we don't have the bricks to lay the rest
of the house
so there's that aspect and then i listen
with the raiders
what always comes to my mind is can they
just simply afford it
we've heard enough rumors over the last
years do they have the cash
to pay a rogers or stuff like that that
those are three things that at least pop
to my head instantly to maybe why we
don't
hear them so hot with the the roger
situation
you move to las vegas you open a new
stadium and you have no fans at all your
first year there right sure that
affected the cash flow as well for the
raiders but
rogers to the broncos would make it even
harder for the raiders to be anything
other than
yeah at best the third place team in the
afc
west and really the raiders would be the
one team keeping the afc west at that
point from being top to bottom
one of the best divisions in the nfl i
mean and and even then they could go
nine and eight
eight and nine and and still be in last
place
yeah in that division the way it's
currently going uh from one of the
strongest divisions to one of the
weakest
the afc south which shows flashes from
time to time but perpetually clusters
among
top to bottom all four teams the worst
in the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports